That was a trick question. We wanted to
emphasize that affordances and signifiers are quite different
concepts. They're independent. Affordances are the possible actions
an actor can take upon an item in question.
Signifiers are the signal. Signal conveyed to the
person about the possible actions. Something can be
in affordance or a signifier or both or
neither. It could even be a signifier of something
but not afford doing it. The correct
answers to the questions therefore are, the barbed
wire. Yeah, the barbs on the barbed wire,
they're both signifiers and anti-affordances. The danger sign,
yeah, that's a signifier. The site of the
high voltage line? Well, that's a signifier to
some people, but meaningless to others. And a
very high voltage itself is an invisible affordance.
It doesn't afford getting near. You'll kill yourself,
because within, but for a high voltage, if
you're within one meter about three feet, it
can be fatal. But there's nothing to see. It's
invisible, so the very high voltage is actually
at invisible anti-affordance. The doorknob. It's a partial
signifier and an affordance. The signifier is only
partial because it indicates where to do the action,
you know, pushing, or pulling, or turning, but not which action to do.